bonjour Bon week-end bienvenue en
Basse-Normandie dans votre émission là
vous est libre ça y est on connaît le
nom des trois présidents des
départements bas normands j'en ai 11
Dupont le président
udi sortant a été élu dans le Calvados
avec une large majorité il repart pour
un deuxième mandat Alain Lambert
président sortant
udi lui aussi a été reconduit dans
l'Orne avec un total de 25 voix sur 42
et puis Philippe Bas
UMP succède à Jean-François Legrand à la
tête du département de la Manche c'est
une page qui se tourne puisque
Jean-François Legrand était dans ce
fauteuil depuis 17 ans notre invité ce
midi justement c'est le nouveau
président du conseil départemental de la
Manche Philippe bonjour bonjour on va
revenir dans un instant sur votre
élection mais d'abord regardez cette
image c'est en ce moment dans nos locaux
celle de Jean-François Legrand que vous
avez remplacé à la tête du département
qui est en discussion avec un des
nouveaux conseillers départementaux
gauche élus sur Cherbourg c'est Frédéric
Bastian et les deux hommes vous
interpelleront dans quelques minutes sur
ce plateau Chenu est avec nous bonjour
Chenu avec un premier dessin un jour
Franck bonjour monsieur le Président
alors écoutez Jean-François Legrand vous
a tricoté une manche ou un bar à la
mesure de ses idées c'est un personnage
très fort etc alors espérons que ce
département vous ira comme un gant
j'espère que le tricot de Jean-François
Legrand me tiendra chaud surtout il va
vous tenir chaud c'est presque à Damart
alors on le disait c'est une page de
l'histoire de ce département qui se
tourne puisque Jean-François Legrand
était en poste depuis 1998 vous le
retrouverez d'ailleurs dans quelques
minutes sur ce plateau pour échanger
dans un autre rôle vous le verrez
vous avez dit hier lors de votre
élection à la tête de ce département de
la Manche Jean rêvé voilà c'est un rêve
qui s'est accompli justement cette
semaine
c'est vrai que j'en rêvais ça
m'impressionne aussi
quand on est attaché à quelqu'un on se
sent responsable de lui
et quand on est responsable de quelqu'un
on va au bout de sa responsabilité
la Manche
c'est une terre étonnante elle ne le
sait pas le même une terre unique hier
j'ai pas si de tes Tocqueville j'aurais
dû le faire
j'ai cité Montesquieu parce que comment
expliquer cette personnalité si
singulière de la Manche
par son peuplement par le climat par la
géographie par l'histoire sans doute
toutes ses composantes
et c'est très curieux de voir que nous
sommes une terre où vous avez d'un côté
invente tonique qui peut souffler fort
et fouetter le visage puis d'un autre
côté un soleil paisible qui permet aux
cultivateur de creuser son sillon et
l'âme de la Manche elle est faite de ce
goût du Grand Large de l'aventure mais
aussi de cette exigence de stabilité de
sécurité de travail qui se tournent
c'est le mélange des deux qui fait toute
sa force vous avez déclaré je rends
hommage à Jean-François Legrand car il
incarne la Manche en ajoutant j'aurais
besoin de lui pour qu'il me passe le
témoin ça veut dire que vous allez
continuer à travailler ensemble là dans
les prochaines semaines les prochains
mois et que ça n'est pas tout de suite
je dirais que vous rentrez en poste et
que vous décidez de tout
je décide de tout ce qui me revient dès
maintenant avec mes collègues du conseil
départemental et ça n'empêche pas de
m'inscrire aussi dans une continuité qui
comporte une dimension de relation
personnelle et amicale qui s'est tissé
au fil des années et je reconnais à
Jean-François Legrand la capacité
d'éclairer et s'il le veut bien je ne
manquerai pas de le solliciter
régulièrement alors on va revenir sur
votre parcours à parcours atypique
puisque vous avez été ministre
secrétaire général de l'Elysée aux côtés
de Jacques Chirac vous êtes arrivés en
2008 dans le département de la Manche en
devenant conseiller général de
saint-poids c'est un petit canton moins
de 4000 habitants votre portefeuille 900
portrait et je vous laisse la parole
dans un instant portrait signé Bernard
Coulet
ont sûrement influencé son adhésion à
l'UMP Monsieur Nicolas Sarkozy
dites-moi comment on devient ministre de
la Santé secrétaire général de l'Elysée
a excusez-moi simple conseiller général
de saint-poids vous le rappeliez 2500
habitants c'est un choix de vie
c'est une sorte de vocation qui
s'accomplit et de vocation de jeunesse
et puis c'est aussi le désir de leur
acidement j'ai beaucoup enfants déménagé
j'ai grandi dans plusieurs provinces de
France et j'étais un petit peu orphelin
d'une terre en réalité quand j'ai
terminé cette vie publique nationale que
vous avez rappelé et quand j'ai été élu
à saint-poy j'ai ressenti l'effet d'une
sorte d'adoption j'étais orphelin d'une
terre et je suis devenu un fils de
Normandie un fils de la mort et c'est ce
que vous avez déclaré lors de votre
discours cette semaine
on peut pas dire et on l'a rappelé dans
le sujet et que les débuts votre arrivée
dans ce département de la Manche était
facile puisque vous avez subi une
première défaite en 2007 au législative
c'était un échec et après il y a eu
cette élection dans ce canton de
saint-poids est-ce que vous êtes dit en
2007 peut-être que je ne n'y arriverai
jamais c'est pas le bon endroit on avait
parlé de parachutage à l'époque et bien
justement
un parachuté c'est quelqu'un que vous ne
connaissez pas vous ne savez pas qui il
est et en particulier vous ne savez pas
s'il est sincère les gens ne connaissez
peut-être et je crois que il y avait le
besoin effectivement
de me connaître le besoin que nous nous
connaissions puis le besoin de montrer
jour après jour la fidélité la sincérité
et je crois que une fois que
vous êtes reconnu que vous faites partie
de la famille alors tout va bien sans
poids aujourd'hui
cette ma communauté mais ça change des
salons parisiens des ministères
quand on travaille comme j'ai travaillé
toute ma vie les salons parisiens en ne
les connaît pas car quand on rentre chez
soi on a qu'une idée en tête dormir un
peu
vous habitez toujours à Saint-Ouen
j'habite près de Sainte-Foy où j'ai
maintenant ma maison où je peux avoir ma
famille mes amis
et donc ça consolidait encore cette
ancrage parce que je suis propriétaire
d'un petit bout de cette terre de manche
à laquelle je suis tellement attaché et
qu'est-ce qui vous a séduit dans ce
département de la Manche puisque vous
auriez pu choisir un autre lieu une
autre région pourquoi je ne crois pas
avoir jeté votre destinée sur ce
département je ne crois pas d'abord ce
département de n'était pas étranger je
suis fils d'un hormones l'extérieur
j'étais régulièrement et souvent pour
des raisons personnelles et familiales
dans le département j'avais appris à le
connaître
et voilà les choses se sont faites
simplement comme
et naturellement comme elle se font
partout
alors on va parler de questions qui
fâche un peu plus je dirais puisque vous
êtes président du département de la
Manche mais vous êtes aussi sénateur
président de la commission des lois au
Sénat en 2017 vous devrez faire un choix
Philippe Bas vous ne pourrez pas si la
loi reste en l'état
conserver votre poste de président du
département de la Manche et celui de
sénateur que ferez-vous mais vous avez
bien formulé la question je crois qu'il
ne faut pas que la loi reste en état je
pense que il est bon
pour les habitants du territoire mais il
est aussi bon pour le Parlement français
d'avoir des élus qui est à la fois une
capacité
nationale mais aussi un ancrage profond
dans le territoire en y exerçant des
responsabilités vous savez quand Bernard
Cazeneuve était député maire de
Cherbourg à cette époque je n'ai jamais
entendu quelqu'un dire c'est un mauvais
député parce qu'il est maire ou c'est un
mauvais maire parce qu'il est député et
de la même façon quand Jean-François
Legrand a été président du conseil
général et sénateur il a rendu
compatible ces deux fonctions pour le
bien de ces électeurs la loi la
responsabilité politique sera applicable
en 2017 la responsabilité politique ne
se fragmente pas
quand les gens viennent vous voir parce
qu'ils ont un problème ils ne regardent
pas le code des collectivités
territoriales pour savoir si c'est le
maire le président du Département le
sénateur qui est compétent ils veulent
que le problème soit résolu et bien pour
résoudre les problèmes de la Manche on a
besoin de personnalités qui est la
capacité d'apporter des réponses et
c'est de là-dedans que je m'inscris
alors maintenant vous me posez
précisément la question ne croyez pas je
l'oublie ni que je l'ai dûe ni qu'elle
me fâche puisque j'assume pleinement
cela mais s'il y a un choix à faire
lequel ferez-vous un choix à faire je
vais d'abord vous dire que la loi doit
être rééquilibrée parce qu'elle va trop
loin et s'il y a un choix à faire
excusez moi de vous dire que je le ferai
le moment venu c'est pas décidé pour le
moment alors on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler sur ce plateau je l'espère
votre élection sur le canton de
Villedieu on l'a suivi dans nos journaux
et dans nos émissions spéciales a été
émaillée d'un incident des bulletins de
vote qui possédaient de la couleur
couleur orange précisément ce qui est
interdit par le code électoral le binôme
divers gauche qui est arrivé en
troisième position à déposer un recours
pour demander l'annulation du scrutin
est-ce que vous imaginez de voir
retourner devant les électeurs dans les
semaines ou les mois qui viennent non
d'abord je n'aurais pas le crainte j'ai
été élu avec presque les trois quarts
des voix deuxièmement je dois vous dire
que je suis juriste et je suis pas
tellement heureux d'avoir laissé
échapper cette erreur
les cordonniers
ne sont pas toujours les mieux chaussées
mais c'est une erreur vraiment
microscopique personne n'a été induit en
erreur par ce bulletin il faut vraiment
un certain esprit de chicane de
polémique que je peux comprendre dans
une campagne mais qui est à moins de
justification après une campagne pour
aller faire de la procédure une
procédure
qui est vraiment à 100% de
de probabilité 100% que le tribunal
administratif rejette car vraiment les
questions de
droit électoral elles sont tellement
banales tellement tranchées depuis un
siècle dans notre République on annule
pas scrutin quand il y a pas eu une
manœuvre qui a induit en erreur les
électeurs et qui compte tenu d'un faible
écart de voix peut avoir altéré la
sincérité du scrutin mais bulletin ont
été reconnus valables par la commission
départementale présidé par un magistrat
il y a vraiment strictement aucun
problème donc pour le résultat de
l'élection il y aura pas un nouveau vote
c'est sûr
alors en fin d'année il y a une autre
certitude s'il y a pas de nouvelles
élections sur Villedieu et
vous entendent effectivement le code
électoral ne permet pas à m'entendre
c'est une certitude c'est la vérité
d'avoir un recours contre cette élection
il y aura des élections régionales sur
la grande Normandie ça c'est une
certitude ah oui au moins vous présentez
comme un défenseur du département de la
Manche et de la Basse-Normandie vous
dites il faudra éviter qu'il y ait une
forte attraction vers l'île de France
qu'est-ce que vous dites dans ce sens là
justement c'est que il y a crainte que
léonormand se
prennent la plus grosse part du gâteau
tire la couverture à eux j'ai accepté la
création de la grande Normandie
je vais voter
mais la grande Normandie elle ne doit
pas être
déséquilibrée
vers l'est c'est à dire vers l'île de
France quand vous êtes à Rouen il y a
beaucoup d'équipements dont vous n'avez
pas besoin parce que vous les avez à une
heure en allant en région parisienne
quand vous êtes chez nous
vous avez besoin des équipements et par
conséquent un des premiers enjeux pour
moi comme président du département de la
Manche et comme sénateur c'est de faire
en sorte que
l'équilibre soit assuré et que nos
projets soient pleinement pris en compte
alors je vais citer un tweet simplement
que vous avez lancé
sur votre compte c'était hier matin nous
sommes sur le bon chemin pour remporter
la Normandie réunifiée en décembre alors
on ne sait pas si ça sera en décembre ou
si ça sera avancé d'ailleurs ces
élections au 22 au 29 novembre c'est en
débat apparemment il n'y a pas de
certitude là-dessus sur la date précise
de ces élections autre question quel
capital pour la grande Normandie et là
le débat a été lancé quel équilibre
entre rond et quand je vous propose
d'écouter Hervé Morin député de l'Eure
était de liste Uli pour les prochaines
régionales
bien partager sur le territoire mettre
la Normandie en réseau faire en sorte
que les artères de la Normandie irrigue
l'ensemble des métropoles normandes
voilà l'idée qui est la nôtre et dans
cette construction là dès lors que vous
mettez la préfecture de région à Rouen
vous devez mettre le conseil régional à
Caen et puis quand est mieux des
services et plus central quand on est à
Cherbourg ou quand on est à Rouen on est
à peu près au milieu et rien que pour ça
ça méritait d'y penser voilà Rouen
préfecture quand siège du Conseil
régional vous êtes d'accord avec lui
j'imagine non on en a pas parlé ensemble
il y a beaucoup de choses dont
j'aimerais parler à ceux qui veulent le
faire dans les mois qui viennent ils
veulent se présenter à la présidence de
la région parce que il faut que je
veille au grain dans l'intérêt de notre
territoire le partage entre les villes
c'est une solution de compromis
la vérité c'est que quand comme le dit
Hervé Morin est au centre et aurait
vocation à regrouper l'ensemble des
services publics ou en tout cas des
services publics régionaux que ce soit
la préfecture ou le conseil régional
c'est quelque chose de soutenez très
clairement je ne baisserai oui la
réponse est oui je ne baisserai pas la
garde sur un tel sujet en cherchant un
compromis sans avoir des garanties de
ceux qui prétendent être président de la
nouvelle région normande sur la priorité
qu'il donneront au projet que nous avons
à défendre sur notre territoire
alors j'aimerais qu'on évoque un autre
sujet et connaître votre avis sur une
des actualités de la semaine c'est cette
reprise partielle des abattoirs aim le
tribunal de commerce de Coutances a
accepté deux offres de reprise dont une
qui concerne l'abattoir Sainte-Cécile
près de Villedieu c'est sur votre canton
précisément on a beaucoup parlé durant
la campagne électorale 206 emplois vont
être sauvés mais 150 ont être supprimés
je vous laisse la parole dans un instant
mais avant cela on écoute une des
salariés c'était cette semaine
206 emplois malgré que s'il y en a qui
ont été censés à imvivra
quand même
et puis je pense à tous nos élus là qui
se sont battus qui ont monté le dossier
qu'on fait un trap du tonnerre jour et
nuit
grâce à eux moi il y aura 26 ans pas de
sauver quand même
voilà 206 emplois de sauver 150
supprimer que répondez-vous à cette
femme cette salarié justement au bord
des larmes on le voit oui vous avez
mesuré la charge émotionnelle évidemment
ces familles qui sont comme vous l'avez
rappelé pour beaucoup autour de chez moi
elle vivent des moments depuis
le 23 décembre qui sont terribles elles
ont dû faire preuve de beaucoup de
sang-froid pour tenir jusque là il y a
eu trois projets de reprise successives
qui ont avorté et là on était au bord du
gouffre et les salariés se sont
eux-mêmes pris en main parce que c'était
la dernière chance le dernier espoir et
les collectivités plus l'État ont
accepté de les accompagner mais
maintenant c'est pas la dernière étape
il faut rester sur le pont ce sera dur
très dur nous avons franchi une une
étape c'est très difficile
mais il y en a d'autres devant nous qui
sachent simplement
que ils sont pas seuls qu'ils sont aidés
mais ils ont beaucoup à faire eux-mêmes
pour affiner le projet pour rendre
viable l'entreprise la formule juridique
qu'on fasse une nouvelle société une
scope ça ne résout pas à soi tout seul
le problème de la rentabilité il faut
que l'avenir soit un avenir des
bénéfices pour cet on sait que le
département et la région ont été acteurs
dans la reprise de ces abattoirs à im on
a pointé du doigt dans la faillite
justement des abattoirs le contexte
international la crise forcée mais
également des problèmes de gestion
apparemment comment est-ce que vous
comptez exercer votre surveillance
pour ne pas que de nouvelles erreurs se
reproduisent vous allez avoir un regard
sur les comptes de l'entreprise en tant
que partenaire je dirais de cette
reprise nous sommes associés à cette
reprise mais nous ne sommes pas les
repreneurs nous n'avons pas fait une
sorte de nationalisation départementale
ou régionales des abattoirs et donc il y
a de notre part l'exigence effectivement
d'une surveillance mais en même temps
nous ne sommes pas les patrons de
l'entreprise et nous ne pouvons pas
l'être nous n'avons pas le droit d'être
et nous ne se et nous nous serions
d'ailleurs de mauvais patron mais ça
veut dire effectivement que dans le
dialogue avec les nouveaux dirigeants
qui vont être mis en place nous seront
très exigus exigeants alors on va
accueillir dans un instant Frédéric
Bastian qui est un des nouveaux élus du
conseil départemental de la Manche élu
divers gauche il l'a emporté sur le
canton de Cherbourg 1 dimanche dernier
on le voit là aux côtés du maire de
Cherbourg Jean-Michel Houlgate qui
annonce sa victoire d'ailleurs les
applaudissements c'était dimanche
dernier Frédéric Bastian qui va donc
nous rejoindre sur ce plateau bonjour
monsieur Bastien
sur le canton de Cherbourg 1 vous avez
entendu phidi basse exprimé pendant
quelques minutes qu'avez-vous à lui dire
quelle question avez-vous à lui poser
ecoutez Philippe bye était élu hier
président du département de la Manche et
je leur félicite et je voudrais tout
simplement lui pour la première question
lui posait comment compte-t-il
travailler avec l'opposition dont je
fais partie
je n'aime pas ce monoposition je préfère
dire la minorité parce que vous n'êtes
pas tenu de vous opposer à tout et
d'ailleurs votre représentante qui était
candidate à la présidence du conseil
départemental Yvelines
Druez a fait a tenu un propos que je
trouve de ce point de ce point de vue
très prometteur nous allons travailler
ensemble
je suis président du Département vous
êtes élu de Cherbourg
mais vous êtes élu de Cherbourg pour
tout le département mais en même temps
vous êtes pour moi un interlocuteur sur
Cherbourg avec le président de la
Communauté urbaine avec le maire avec
les maires des communes voisines vous
êtes légitime comme je le suis et nous
avons ensemble à agir pour le
développement pour la solidarité et nous
allons le faire sur la base de relation
humaine qui j'en suis sûr seront bonnes
et si nous avons des différences de
points de vue vous en avez aussi à
l'intérieur de la minorité
départementale j'en ai à l'intérieur de
la majorité départementale ça ne nous
arrête pas pour construire ensemble
voilà mon souhait est-ce que c'est la
manière nouvelle de faire de la
politique justement c'est que Bastian
pas de clivage droit de gauche au
département
une tradition qui avait été lancée par
Jean-François Legrand qu'on recevra dans
la politique les propos les propos tenus
y compris hier par Monsieur le Président
disons que le temps de la campagne était
terminé que aujourd'hui et maintenant on
devait se mettre au travail au service
des manchois me semble effectivement des
propos dans laquelle l'opposition ou la
minorité parce qu'effectivement le terme
minorité s'adresse peut-être convient
vous convient j'en suis d'accord à
gauche sur le président et on met on
sera néanmoins s'opposé quand il le
faudra mais en tout cas il y a
effectivement je le crois plus de sujets
en ce qui concerne la manche qui nous
rassemble que de sujets qui nous
opposent et je crois que c'est le sens
de notre engagement au service des
manchois ça veut dire que la tonalité a
changé depuis dimanche soir je vais
simplement citer ce que vous disiez
Frédéric Bastian au soir de votre
élection à la mairie de Cherbourg le
Nord Cotentin est un secteur où le rose
est indélébile on est bien dans des
clivages politiques c'était j'ai réagi à
un propos que j'ai trouvé maladroit de
la part de Monsieur Gosselin qui avait
adressé lors d'un meeting la phrase
suivante Gaumont cette tâche rose du
Nord Cotentin et j'avais répondu que
cette tâche rose était indélébile non
pas pour la couleur mais pour les
valeurs qui sont portées par ce
territoire des valeurs de solidarité des
valeurs d'ambition pour notre territoire
et enfin des valeurs de vivre ensemble
voilà c'était plus sur ce terrain là que
je réagissais alors la manche c'est 350
km de côte le Nord Cotentin dont on
parlait il y a un instant et considéré
comme un des plus beaux endroits de la
région est-ce que demain les élus du
département que vous êtes s'engageront
pour faire en sorte que ce littoral
reste protégé ça avait été une des
grandes missions de Jean-François
Legrand faire en sorte de développer
l'économie les énergies marines
renouvelables mais également de protéger
le caractère naturel de ce beau
département qui la mange l'un et l'autre
la Manche demain ça donne quoi on la
dessine comment elle ressemble à quoi
cette alors en ce qui en ce qui nous
concerne en ce qui concerne le
Territoire
du Nord Cotentin que vous mettiez un
petit peu en évidence notamment ce qui
concerne les énergies marines
renouvelables moi je crois qu'on peut
saluer on doit saluer aujourd'hui le
travail et la dynamique qui a été
réalisée par nos prédécesseurs et cette
dynamique au-delà des politique
Jean-François Legrand Bernard Cazeneuve
Laurent Beauvais ont su insuffler une
véritable dynamique qui est porteuse
d'avenir industriel pour notre
territoire et de faire de demain du Nord
Cotentin très clairement un territoire
d'excellence du mix énergétique qui
réunira le nucléaire l'hydrolien
l'hydrogène pardon
l'hydrolien et l'éolien offshore donc de
ce point de vue là je crois que j'ose
espérer que monsieur le Président
Philippe Bas continuera dans cette
dynamique qui a été instituée
de la mer c'est ça comparé à d'autres
départements après plus terrien je
dirais là il faut tirer profit de ce
littoral pour alors développer
l'économie touristique peut-être on y
viendra tout à l'heure mais aussi faire
un pôle d'excellence des énergies marin
renouvelables c'est ce que vous dites
oui je pense que une et c'est ainsi que
c'est déjà engagé je crois que la
dynamique est engagée de ce point de vue
là je crois aussi très clairement qu'il
faut bien évidemment protéger le les
atouts touristiques de notre territoire
mais très je pense que les deux ne sont
pas incompatibles et qui a probablement
des des choses à faire dans les deux
sens si vous deviez justement je faisais
la question à Frédéric Bastien et un
instant imaginez la Manche vous venez
d'arriver Philippe Bas mais je vous pose
déjà la question dans 6 ans dans 10 ans
ça serait quoi comme département
c'est un département qui serait
exactement avec son identité d'abord il
faut vraiment jouer notre force et notre
force c'est le caractère de la Manche ce
caractère de la Manche je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est le caractère de la
terre et de la mer conjuguée et nous
avons à la fois la patience de
construire le goût du travail bien fait
et le sens de la conquête de l'aventure
nous sommes prêts à embarquer et cette
en mélangeant ces qualités que nous
allons construire cette manche et je
crois que il faut la construire ensemble
c'est sûr et que la mère elle est
vraiment un domaine dont nous ne
mesurons pas suffisamment les ressources
il y a les oligos et les mots les
perspectives en matière de pharmacie des
ressources marines c'est des choses dont
on parle jamais mais c'est chez nous
aussi nous avons envoyé développer
toutes ces richesses
qui faisait référence à
pointe du Cotentin avec le nom de
Bernard Cazeneuve qui apparaissait voilà
un mot connu justement pour le
commentaire rapidement oui finalement il
y a une merveille au sud du Mont
Saint-Michel une merveille au nord et
puis peut-être que Philippe Bas va
incarner la Merveille du milieu enfin
voilà de la ville préfecture ce
qu'il faut pas les oublier aussi
franchement Frédéric Bastien vous avez
été élu en 2008 sur une liste qui était
menée par Bernard Cazeneuve justement
c'est quelque chose que vous allez
perpétuer dans l'action écoutez ce que
j'ai appris avec Bernard Cazeneuve qui
avait fait appel à moi c'est très
clairement l'écoute le respect des
convictions de chacun et prendre en
compte
la notion de rassemblement il disait
souvent une collectivité quelle qu'elle
soit c'est comme une famille on peut
avoir des disputes on peut avoir mais on
doit en ressortir unis comme une famille
et je m'applique effectivement ce
concept qui nous permet de travailler et
du coup avec des gens d'horizons et
d'opinion différentes tant qu'on trouve
des points de convergence et on sait
chauffage je le crois très sincèrement
que nous avons en ce qui concerne la
Manche et nous prédécesseurs l'ont
démontré beaucoup plus de points de
convergence que de divergence pour notre
territoire donc
UMP et divers gauche n'est pas encarté
aux parties socialiste mais ils peuvent
travailler ensemble pour le département
de la Manche que l'on soit à la tête du
département ou ministre d'État comme
c'est le cas pour Bernard Cazeneuve
c'est un peu la morale de l'histoire
c'est ça
une découverte heureusement
on peut dire que la Manche a formé et
donnée à la France un nouvel homme
d'État avec Bernard casanov je crois que
il assume cette fonction de ministère de
ministre de l'intérieur avec beaucoup
d'autorités de sang-froid et de respect
du droit
au fond c'est bon pour le pays c'est bon
pour nous je ne vais pas sous prétexte
que je ne suis pas de son bord politique
de critiquer systématiquement
par ça et le message sera passé merci
Frédéric Bastien d'avoir participé à
cette émission on se retrouve juste
après le journal de la mi-journée et
nous aurons un invité pas surprise mais
quelqu'un qui rêve de vous interroger
Philippart à tout de suite
bonjour bonjour retour dans votre
émission la voix libre nous recevons ce
midi le nouveau président du conseil
départemental de la Manche Philippe Bas
vous avez succédé à Jean-François
Legrand qui soit resté 17 ans à la tête
du département que fera Jean-François
Legrand maintenant on lui a posé la
question c'était dans notre journal il y
a quelques jours je vais conserver quand
même des activités puis je vais lire je
vais écrire et si d'aventure vous avez
besoin de moi je suis prêt à la Franck
baigner vous présenter La voix est Libre
il y a quelques jours en direct dans
notre journal des saints de Chenu
alors jean-François Le Grand bonjour
justement alors bonjour bonjour mon cher
collègue je suis passé je dois vous
appeler comme ça oui maintenant puisque
vous avez changé de vous inquiétez pas
par rapport à ce qu'a dit Chanu non je
n'ai pas l'intention de vous prendre la
place sauf peut-être dans le temps mais
on verra
bon pour aujourd'hui chaud nue
alors on peut dire que vous êtes à
laisser là pendant quelques quelques
minutes après avoir occupé ce poste de
président du département de la Manche
pendant 17 ans et vous avez face à vous
justement Philippe Bas qui vous a
succédé alors
je vous laisse poser la première
question de journaliste question
évidemment impertinente sévère avec
beaucoup de pertinence comme d'habitude
les journalistes le font ou alors s'il y
a de la pertinence C'est vous qui le
dites bonjour Philippe et puis bravo
pour ta ton élection brillante et en
même temps Jean-François avec une
première observation c'est que je vais
reprendre à mon compte le dessin de
shonu tout à l'heure où il me situait
au-dessus du Mont Saint-Michel en disant
la force soit avec toi alors que la
force soit avec toi puisque Clémenceau
disant disait vivement ce soir qu'on
soit élu que les emmerdements commencent
alors parmi les difficultés que tu vas
avoir affrontées d'abord présider un
conseil territorial un conseil
départemental c'est de voir d'abord
gérer l'ensemble des problématiques qui
se posent mais c'est en même temps avoir
le souci de l'anticipation et de
projeter le territoire qu'on a l'honneur
de présider vers l'avenir alors je vais
reprendre je vais revenir sur ce qui
était dit votre question
tout à l'heure à propos de la mer la mer
c'est un gisement fabuleux qui va
largement au-delà des EMR au-delà de la
pêche de la coaculture des problèmes
littoraux il y a là devant nous quelque
chose de tout à fait extraordinaire et
on a 350 km de côte comment est-ce que
tu comptes peut-être on vous voit les
invités non je ne vous vois pas parce
que je lui dis toujours tu donc je vois
pas je vais pas changer aujourd'hui ça
va vous changer un peu vous verrez quand
je vous tutoirez le temps sera grave et
donc comment comptes-tu organiser un peu
cette gouvernance pour porter tout ce
gisement extraordinaire que la mer
d'abord vous ne mettez dans une
situation impossible il vous l'a pas dit
mais enfin c'est la première fois et
qu'on se parle devant des milliers dieux
témoins de notre de notre discussion on
va faire Jean-François comme si les
autres n'étaient pas là
tu soulèves un problème pour lequel je
vais pas trouver la réponse du jour au
lendemain parce que
le problème en réalité assez compliqué
je pense que c'est parce qu'il est
compliqué que nous n'avons pas encore
su donner toutes les impulsions parce
qu'en réalité quand on parle de la mère
on parle de tas de choses qui sont très
différents la mer mais en facteur commun
des choses qui relèvent d'activité de
recherche des choses qui relèvent de
l'innovation des choses qui relèvent
d'activité économique bien connues la
pêche lostriculture les choses qui
relèvent de la protection du milieu
naturel les choses qui relèvent de
liaison maritimes il faut mettre tout ça
ensemble pour concevoir une vraie
politique de la mère alors nous aurons
dans l'équipe des vices présidents
quelqu'un comme Valérie nouvelle qui va
porter les grands projets qui sont en
cours éolienne en mer etc mais il nous
faut aussi côté pêche agriculture
mobilisée les énergies et donc moi ce
que je compte faire c'est réunir tous
ceux qui
un titre ou un autre en quelque chose à
voir avec la découverte du potentiel
maritime de développement pour pour la
Manche de façon à ce que on arrive
vraiment pour le faire à
mettre en place en fédérant toutes les
énergies tous les organismes de la
recherche les universités de sorte que
on arrive vraiment à avoir une politique
de la mère qui pourrait être vraiment un
pôle national de développement des
ressources marines dans la main je vais
pas vous laisser tout seul complètement
il est revenu je suis revenu maintenant
faut quand même que je puisse intervenir
je vais quand même vous accompagner
durant cette fin d'émission
Jean-François Legrand pour la première
fois depuis 39 ans vous avez siéger dans
le public cette semaine on va voir
peut-être cette image puisque vous êtes
conseiller général de laisser depuis
1976 on le rappelait au début de cette
émission président de ce département
depuis 1998 qu'est-ce que ça fait
justement de voir quelqu'un d'autre à
votre place
mais c'est une très grande satisfaction
d'abord de voir que c'est lui
premièrement deuxièmement j'avais
effectivement une très très grande
émotion parce que on ne quitte pas une
assemblée dans laquelle on a vécu
pendant 39 ans sans avoir quelques
quelques noeuds à la gorge mais vous
savez admet très proche d'amis envoyer
ce matin un SMS en me disant ne regrette
pas le passé regretter le passé c'est
comme courir derrière le vent alors je
ne vais pas courir derrière le vent et
je ne regrette pas le passé j'ai eu des
années de bonheur extraordinaire mais je
voudrais quand même un peu revenir faire
mon job celui auquel vous m'avez convié
aujourd'hui et donc dire à Philippe que
il va y avoir dans les compétences qui
vont évoluer entre les départements et
les territoires des sujets qui vont
avoir du mal à être traités de par la
loi des créations monsieur Bastien et
Philippe à l'instant en parler des
créations comme West Normandie énergie
marine qui est une société publique
locale que l'on a créé avec Laurent beau
pour accompagner le développement des
énergies pour accompagner pour
accompagner les énergies renouvelables
renouvelables pour normand associés qui
est un syndicat mixte qu'on a fait
comment est-ce que tu vois ce
positionnement de l'ONEM qui est
aujourd'hui ouest Normandie donc pas
normand et PNA dans le dispositif
régional en fonction des conseils très
rapidement parce que on arrive à la fin
c'est l'émission l'avenir de port
normales
sur un plateau de télévision non bon en
20 secondes mais non pas en 20 secondes
s'il vous plaît voilà je vous demande 30
secondes je me concentre bien pour vous
répondre il est vital que nous entrions
dans la grande Normandie en étant
accueilli avec nos projets dans leur
continuité la région Basse-Normandie est
arrimée au projet de la Manche
aujourd'hui et bien nous devons arrimer
la nouvelle région normande et c'est pas
une histoire de majorité c'est une
histoire de rapport de force entre la
Manche et l'ensemble de la Normandie
nous avons besoin de la région normande
mais elle doit nous écouter car nous
sommes moteurs pour un certain nombre de
grands projets alors quelles sont les
qualités de l'un et l'autre ou poser
cette question Philippe Bas quelle est
la principale qualité de Jean-François
dans les yeux
l'enthousiasme le goût de l'aventure la
chaleur humaine
même question Jean-François Legrand a
Philippe Bas l'enthousiasme il vient de
vous le dire à l'instant par rapport à
cette nouvelle fonction le sens du
service de l'intérêt et de services et
de l'intérêt général et en même temps le
sérieux dans l'accomplissement d'une
mission qui est extraordinaire moi
personnellement je n'y ai connu que du
bonheur je lui souhaite autant de
bonheur que ce que j'ai pu vivre
principalement défaut justement de
Philippe Bas là si on fait le pendant
c'est connu pour ceux qui l'est on le
croit un peu peut-être parfois distant
parfois à peur avec un peu de froideur
alors qu'il est tout le contraire de ça
et même question Jean-François Legrand
son principal défaut l'enthousiasme
rappeler simplement vous avez été son
vice-président de 2008 à 2015 oui en
fait il a eu le temps de me faire à sa
main je vais essayer de m’émanciper
progressivement mais ce sera dur
son principal défaut
lenthousiasme dans l'enthousiasme il y a
le meilleur mais il y a le danger aussi
c'est pour ça qu'il faut mesurer les
risques avant de s'y engager c'est vrai
alors Jean-François Legrand a l'heure
des bilans vous a présenté effectivement
et on le rappelait il y a quelques
instants comme un humaniste un amoureux
de l'environnement qui respecte la
nature on connaît vos différents
engagements on a regardé ce qui s'est
passé durant les 10 dernières années
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
avez envie d'enseigner quelque part à
Philippe Bas ou à d'autres cette manière
l'expérience ne s'enseigne pas on peut
éventuellement l'observer il l'a dit
tout à l'heure si d'aventure il avait
quelque part des interrogations et que
je sois
vraiment par erreur ou par défaut
capable d'apporter peut-être quelques
éléments de compréhension surtout sur
l'historique des choses alors je suis à
son entière disposition mais il faudra
que je trouve le temps puisque
maintenant je vais venir présenter la
voie libre très régulièrement avec
Franck Besnier alors je dis ça n'est pas
un poisson d'avril mais ça il ressemble
ça n'est vraiment un bref voilà donc non
bien sûr mais l'expérience ça ne se
transmet pas ça ne sent saigne pas point
final demain on sait que Philippa lui
sera très occupé à travers fonction de
sénateur de président du Département de
la mort demain très sérieusement plus
sérieusement jean-François Le Grand fait
quoi mais demain je l'ai déjà dit je
vais écrire je vais faire un certain
nombre de choses je vais avoir assiéger
dans la société d'économie mixte qui a
été créé puisque on m'y a on y a inclus
comme personnalité qualifiée je vais
faire la même chose avec West Normandy
énergie mais vous allez vous occuper du
Tour de France et je voulais terminer
sur ce point d'orgue il y a le Tour de
France qui va me prendre beaucoup
beaucoup de temps voilà merci merci
Jean-François Legrand d'avoir joué le
jeu et d'avoir participé à l'interview
de votre successeur Philippa merci ça
c'était vraiment nouveau et c'était une
surprise merci d'avoir participé à cette
voie libre merci Chenu
avec un dernier dessin qu'on découvre
peut-être pas encore fini mais c'est
long de mettre le président enfin le
grand sur un vélo c'est une première
aussi
à tous les trois bon weekend et à la
semaine prochaine merci